[Music]
some acs confessions though
um this is actually this is not actually
acs confessions it's sa confessions so
it's out confessions from south africa
someone oh yeah someone sent this to me
time ago to have a look at their page
and yeah there's some funny [ __ ] on
there south african confession yeah some
funny [ __ ] on there
um so here we go
i watched porn just to see what other
women's vaginas look like because i'm
very insecure about mine
that's sad that's an embarrassing body
thing do you remember that shirt yes i
do
weird show bro but i was hooked but it
was weird i loved it it was very hot but
it was very weird i think it was at my
age it was like what am i looking at
do you know what i mean yes why is this
on terrestrial tv yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it should have been online
it should have been like a pin number
you know we have to type in a skype in
to watch it that's what
i was surprised it was a channel oh my
god it rattled me yeah yeah
anyway
i've been making rap songs for a while
now but never told any of my family or
friends because i was scared of being
made fun of because i was still learning
anyways i finally made a song i thought
pre i thought it was pretty fire i was
driving in the car with my mates and
decided to play this i'm playing music
and decided to play the song to see
their reaction without them knowing it
was me
well they said it was probably the worst
song they've ever heard and then also
disconnected me from the orcs after i
played it i sat in pain for the rest of
the ride
wow
oh [ __ ] imagine
i can never imagine i wouldn't know if
i've made music i would know if it's
trash yes you know what i mean but
people really really don't have that
level like
that is my this is like a bit of a
sidetrack but that is one of my main
like how to explain it
i literally think it is a secret to
success
because in terms of like
say for us for example
[Music]
like
i would never be under any illusion that
this is something we could do when we're
actually really bad at it
like i feel like i'm
self-critical enough to understand
when i can do when i'm good at something
and when i'm not
and like
so any endeavor that i would ever take
up in my life i already know if i'm
going to be good at it or not yeah
i don't ever see a situation where i
genuinely think i'm good at something
and someone has to sit me down like bro
this is [ __ ] like you've chosen the
wrong career path you're terrible at
this
i just don't see that ever happen yeah i
know what you mean i know exactly what
you mean i couldn't be me
but bless him yeah anyway
um really really want to get my nipple
piercings but so afraid that one day
when i have kids my breast milk will
come out like
come out my tit like a sprinkler
that's facts to be fair
oh that's wild gross wild
that is wild
before i swipe right on a guy on tinder
i think about how i would sound moaning
his name and if it doesn't sound hot i
swipe left
that's fair in south africa
just bang ube
dentings
i bet that's a that's a that's that's a
big deal it's a deal breaker it would be
a deal breaker
oh my days my boyfriend is amazing but
my weed dealer and i have such sexual
tension that i can't ignore i definitely
want to try him once and then pretend
like nothing happened oh my god try him
once right i want to try him
oh
that's buff to be fair he's buff lingo
me and my weed dealer have sexual
tension
baffling up
[ __ ]
i'm having my ex's baby and he has no
idea
enjoy that party life because soon
you'll be changing nappies
people are
cruel the worst cruel the worst fraud
that's that's just not on it's just not
on
going to see my ex tomorrow to fetch my
aux cable i left that hers
i think we all know i'm absolutely gonna
rail her for the last time
fair enough aux cable
[ __ ] it out this one reminds me of
euphoria
i'm gonna give a pro tip to the fellas
based on my experience
the bigger the daddy issues the more
fire the coochie
you know if she hates her dad you're in
for the best rounds of your life
that's cassie that is that's cassie
she's got terrible daddy issues she's
got terrific tease
the the
the whole show is based around her tits
it's actually crazy the whole production
is centered
it's centered around cassie's tears it's
mad
when sam levinson was writing this show
he was like i need someone with tease
she's found the ridiculous tits that's
perfect
james they're perfect people reference
them all the time perfect
it doesn't make sense [ __ ] me oh yeah it
literally doesn't make sense and i think
her face isn't even that nice it's not
but she's not ugly she's not she's not
ugly but her face is not great yeah but
the tits make her face look amazing
it's true it's actually true she's got a
body audio oh god that's insane anyway
sorry random yeah at the near the end of
the season one in the prom the prom
episode
when nate was squeezing cheeks yes
what did he say he was squeezed to try
and make maddie jealous
she had a whole arse out and he was
squeezing bare cheeks oh my days and
she's he still left her maddie left her
for money maddie wins every time oh
every time the toxic relationship
is it's annoying turn on to me sexy
honestly
the relationship between nate and maddie
gives me sleepless nights because it
turns me on is the sex it's so toxic
it's so sexy but i love it it's
unbearably sexy
maddie's face to me is
the epitome of sex
she oozes sex appeals she actually loses
sex appeal it's nuts she could never
have cassie c's
it will be game set match
100 game set match 100 nate wouldn't
even look at cassie he wouldn't look at
anyone
guy or girl
he wouldn't look at anyone
back in hell oh man it's a good show
um all right i've been [ __ ] this guy
recently who has a tattoo sleeve and
didn't think much of it
last night we had sex and i noticed a
woman's face on the inside of his bicep
turns out i was looking at his mother's
eyes whilst getting railed by him the
biggest ick ever god imagine
i would never because you just yawned
now as well i would never allow myself
to sneeze or yawn in a toilet because
i'm afraid of poop particles and getting
inside my mouth
that's disgusting but did you know
that's a fact though yeah i saw it on
good morning or this morning or whatever
if you flush with the lid over the lid
open ship shot cause everywhere that
makes me feel sick every fam ever since
i heard that i'm closing it down
always yeah always i don't know i leave
it open on purpose i want to pollute the
whole whole yard your toothbrush murks
this [ __ ] party okay that's disgusting
that's what i'm saying it's disgusting
that's the yeah oh yeah that's gross
that's the first thing i thought of when
when it when i realized what it did i
was like my [ __ ] toothbrush
closing it ever since
nah brother
you're playing you are playing yeah yeah
[ __ ] hell that is great
[Music]